hey dr. Berg here in this short video
we're going to talk about the number one
top food to burn belly fat can you have
do you have a wild idea do you have any
idea what it could be I'm gonna tell you
right now it's this right here protein
but I'm gonna it comes with a package
most these diets out there even the
prepackaged foods the high protein diets
like Atkins diet or protein power all
involve protein except for the
vegetarian diets which actually add some
protein but doesn't work the reason why
protein will help you burn fat is
because it triggers two of the fat
burning hormones one is called growth
hormone and the other one is called
glucagon and those hormones help
dissolve fat but I want to take it one
step further because you need this
there's more information to be known
about this because here's the three
things that you must know if you're
going to do this number one it must not
be a large amount of protein per meal
you if a little bit is good a lot is not
good if you guys start eating more
protein past six ounces per meal like
you start doing eight ounces 10 ounces
12 ounces what's gonna happen you're
gonna put a lot of stress on your liver
because your body has to break down the
success amount of protein our bodies
don't really need a lot of protein in
fact there's people that think that if
they lose their hair or their nails I
just need to get more protein not
necessarily it has to do with the liver
function and the hormone interaction so
I would consume about maybe 3 to 6
ounces of protein per meal ok that's
step one number two that protein must be
quality most of the diet programs out
there use the soy protein isolate
protein powder or the cheap whey protein
powder that is a low quality protein and
if you're replacing that with your own
body protein you're gonna not look
healthy as you lose weight I'll see
people that will do this and they look
older they
don't look healthy it'll look kind of
ragged and looked like a crackhead so we
don't want to we want to add a quality
protein like grass-fed beef grass-fed
you know chickens organic chicken
free-range eggs that's a really good
protein or or wild caught fish those are
all really good quality proteins and
then the third thing and this is what a
like the Atkins diet does not do is they
don't add enough vegetable to rid the
waste of the acid from the protein
protein turns into a waste product if
you have too much of it like it turns
into either ammonia it could occur
pneumonia or uric acid and so if you
consume enough vegetable like 7 cups it
will flush all this waste out of your
body out of your liver and kind of
buffer the kind of the side effect of
the protein effect okay because the
kidneys and liver can kind of get
congested with all this protein so as
long as your vegetables are high then
you can tolerate this protein that would
be the number one top food if you wanted
to burn belly fat or any fat for that
matter because it's a trigger to the to
fat burning hormones